Oh!
Gonna swing when it
comes off that corner.
Put it down.
Just let it go.
Relax.
It's not gonna go anywhere.
[laughs] That's a lot
better there than a minute
ago swinging off the ladder.
Fortunately, no
accidents happened.
A couple of times
some good close
reminders of pay
attention to what
you're doing, because bad
things happen really quick.
First time's always the hardest.
First time's always the
hardest, and once we started,
the second time
worked pretty good.
Let it down.
Good.
Perfect.
The third time worked great.
So it's just a matter of
paying attention to each time
you do something, and then
modifying it a little bit.
Here we go.
Floor's closing.
Wow!
It's all closed up.
It looks like a stage.
Come on up.
Wow!
Look at it!
New York apartment size.
Oh, this is great, Andy!
Pretty solid.
You should be happy with this.
Sometimes you travel out
in bush or remote areas,
and it's a real uneasy
bad-vibe kind of a place,
but this hunting platform just
has really good vibes to it.
So that's the last one.
Yay!
[laughs] Yay!
Let's sit right here.
You can still see over
top of everything.
Yeah, let me try sitting.
What's really cool too is
you can stretch out the sleep
and not worry
about rolling over.
To put the time and energy
into putting something that's
going to be really useful to
us, and comfortable for us to go
back there and spend some
time, and really utilize
that piece of the country.
That-- that's going to pay
off big for us in the future.
[whimpers]
Chris is in the basement.
[laughs]
All right, well, I'm happy.
You happy?
Oh, I am very happy.
Tarzan make Jane new house!
[laughs]